[Music]
japan rebo spa Shonduu Masha Wow bite clean fight
nd naa bap Bob a Jemero Leather
I started coding when I was
81 years old.
Originally,
I don't like that interesting thing.  Do you say that you like
things like that?
[Music]
ok google Please turn on the light in the living room Please set
the temperature of the picture book to 23 degrees
Please tell me the diameter of the school
4 days
anan it frens
anden Data  rap for yours o
I bought a computer for the first time and started using it when I was 58 years old.
Ac was a blue dua
wash away to do for words
.
I'm playing in the park
[Applause]
[Music]
An app game that Tia enjoys Hot or
not It's still the case now, but it's rare
.  But they
don't know what kind of apps we like for the elderly.
Wakamiya-san should just put it on by
himself.
Come on.
My name is Yama.
Yeah
ganbare Geller Renu Main Gate Perfect Music Good. The
number of downloads is 100,000
now. I think it's a farm
.
I thought it was wonderful to be able to get various information from all over the world. Well, I thought that
this
net number was something that gave that human awesomeness.
Adem ebner 4 me to do Packer
Esperfa web give pass down re
big story